the main villain of denny villeneuve's
june baron vladimir hakonen is portrayed
with oily gruff menace by stalin
skarsgard but who exactly is this gross
powerful man with a penchant for
hovering feet above the ground this is
june's villain vladimir hakonen
explained baron vladimir hakonen wasn't
always an unappealing mound of menace
and rolls of fat in fact he used to be
quite the looker in his younger days
vladimir was closer to a classic fantasy
bad guy with a well-trained frame red
gold hair and the requisite villainous
widow's peak by the time june takes
place years of debauchery have turned
the baron into the kind of man you see
in the movie so massive that he relies
on lifting devices known as suspensers
to move around there's also an expanded
dune universe take of the barons and
savory appearance which involves a
condition he contracted as a punishment
for certain particularly disgusting
actions i've never met harkenisms before
i have they're not human they're brutal
frank herbert's first new novel came out
in 1965 and when the author crafted a
bad guy for the book he didn't mess
around the baron is a ruthless sadist in
pretty much every aspect in fact the
gross manipulative monster in dediville
nerves june spares audiences the worst
of it as sinister as he is in the film
he's still a heavily revamped version of
the character's irredeemable print
version villeneuve recognized that
certain aspects of the book's baron
wouldn't work for modern sensibilities
which is why he gave the character a
pretty heavy redesign
kill them all
stalin skarsgard is a wonderful actor
but even he requires some assistance to
transform into a hovering 600 pound
space desperate as the los angeles times
reports jenny villeneuve wanted to turn
him into a huge yet physically
frightening presence i was trying to
bring him closer to the spirit of a
gorilla than a fat baby i wanted to get
away from a feeling of decadence and
more toward a feeling of power according
to usa today this required the 70 year
old skarsgard to wear an 88 pound
prosthetic suit with a hidden calling
system for the role and the makeup
process was nothing short of arduous in
fact turning scar's guard into baron
harkin took 6.5 hours and freeing him
from the layers of prosthetics and
makeup at the end of the day took a
further too this cgi-free approach
demanded a lot from skarsgard but
allowed for a realistic and terrifying
performance hakanen sounds like a pretty
good made-up name for a sci-fi villain
but according to june wiki there's
actually a pretty solid and surprisingly
grounded etymology behind it the series
takes place in humanity's faraway future
and the name has evolved from the
finnish surname hakonen per brian
herbert's book the dreamer of june the
biography of frank herbert the harkening
finland connection is indeed correct but
that doesn't mean it's all that deep the
june author apparently found the harsh
sounding name in a phone book the idea
that baron harkinin's house has its
origins in this nordic country is a
fascinating one today you might know
finland as one of the happiest countries
in the world with a unique relationship
to metal music however fast forward far
enough into the future and these
peaceful headbangers might well be the
biggest most depraved tyrants around at
least in june's world their cruelty to
my people is all i've known
the 2021 dune has already given you
skarsgard's vladimir hakonen and his
ruthless nephew the equally waxy looking
but far more physically formidable
glossu rabban however house harkonnen's
most charismatic monster is still
lurking in the shadows this would be
fade ralpher harkinin the baron's
favorite nephew casual fans might mostly
remember fade from sting's turn as a
character in the david lynch version of
june threatening as he is he also
memorably wears a futuristic winged cod
piece speedo which might somewhat
undermine the terror but don't think for
a second that the character is a joke
fade is a wicked smart and charismatic
person who's also one of the absolute
best fighters in the known universe
essentially he's a dark mirror image of
protagonists for the tradies in that
they come from a fairly similar
background but while paul's house is a
noble one fade has been fully
assimilated into the ambitious sadistic
culture of house harkening young fade is
conspicuously absent from vilnav's june
part 1 but might just get to make his
grand entrance in the potential sequel
in many ways he's the final ace in baron
harkin in sleeve a critical part of a
story that's only just begun
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one